IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S HASHTAG HASHTAG
WARS.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU A HASHTAG
AND 60 SECRETARY SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND YOU WILL BUZZ IN WITH
AS MANY TWEETS CAUSE AND 100
POINTS FOR EACH CORRECT EXAMPLE.
AS AN IN MEMORIAL TRIBUTE TO
BLOCKBUSTER VIDEO, GUYS, THE
HASHTAG IS FAILED BUSINESSES.
EXAMPLES OF FAILED BUSINESSES
MIGHT BE, BROWN JULIUS.
OR RELAX THE FRONT.
SO THOSE OF YOU GUYS CAN PLAY AT
HOME ALONG WITH @MIDNIGHT.
JASON.
>> JAWMA JEWS.
>> COULD I HAVE A LITTLE PROTEIN
IN THERE?
>> YES, YOU CAN.
>> RANDY.
>> FOREVER 61.
>> YES, FOREVER 61.
WELL PLAYED.
RON FUNCHES.
>> 50 PEW.
>> IS IT BAD THAT I WANT THAT?
>> PAULA DEEN'S CRACKENER A
BARREL.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE ).
>> I CAN SEE THAT.
JASON.
>> BED, BATH, AND BENEATH.
>> YEAH, OKAY.
NO?
THE CROWD WASN'T WITH YOU ON
THAT ONE.
NO POINTS, NO POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
RANDY.
>> SIZZLER.
THAT WAS A TERRIBLE IDEA,
TERRIBLE IDEA.
>> POINTS, POINT.
JASON.
>> JERRY SANDUSKY'S DISCOVERY
ZONE.
YOU GET POINTS.
RON FUNCHES.
>> SONGS FOR SENIORS.
>> WHICH YOU CAN GET AT FOREVER